hey guys I'm back at Roseanne's kitchen
table and if you don't know what we're
doing here there's an annotation right
here and you can find out although if
you're watching this on mobile they tell
me annotations don't show up on mobile
but trust me we're at Roseanne's kitchen
table and I'm bringing in some of my
favorite guests from the room in port so
you can kind of talk to people I can
talk to people and a little more of an
informal way find out a little bit more
about them personally and I have one of
my favorite personal people Slappy's
with the miss Kelly Carlin Kelly what's
going on I don't know but since we're in
Roseanne's kitchen can we go through her
cabinets there's a lot of great stuff
she has her own salsa over there do you
know that my macadamia did well we know
about the Macan right that's but she is
her own branded salsa okay we'll try
macadamia nuts salsa thing later there's
something that we could you there I'm
doing good otherwise oh very good yeah
so what I wanted to talk about today was
the online and real world and how they
mesh together because Kelly and I have
sort of the exact it's like the
prototypical how these worlds crash into
each other because basically because I
loved her father George Carlin I found
out about you through Twitter I had you
on my sirius XM show you then connected
me with someone at the young turks to do
the point i sort of jokingly said to
someone at the young turks can i do a
show with you guys they said yes and
then basically that lays out the next
two years of my life that we've become
really close and had a zillion other
coincidences like that that sort of
blend the online thing and the and the
real world thing and I just think it's
really cool and I think it's happening
to everyone I just think there's some
meat there and I know you like this cut
this topic in this kind of stuff yeah
it's there it is it's I mean if this
thing has changed our world this social
media thing I watched boyhood last night
the film and part of the cool thing
about obviously is watching everyone
grow up but the technology changes
during the film too and I was really
like aware of that like wow ten years
ago none of this was happening eight
years ago none of this was happening and
so yeah there's this weird I mean for me
I feel like when I'm online especially
like I don't know what's like four years
ago when we met maybe yeah that's when
you actually felt like it was kind of
like a small dinner party kind of a feel
like especially to Twitter yeah you know
now it's kind of like a mall or
something well now everyone's making
everyone everyone swiping which way do
you swipe on tender you're a married
woman oh I don't know which way either
but yes everyone's meeting everything
when we met that first night I saw I it
had you on my show which was by phone
and then we met for drinks one night and
I remember thinking whoa I'm meeting
someone off Twitter right like this is
gonna be okay yeah and now and so you
have these parties at your place every
couple weeks which we've talked about on
the show before and there's tons of
people there that have connected yeah
Twitter in this whole thing yeah i mean
it's it's become i mean some of them
it's like I know them but didn't know
them and then other people I like I mean
I don't know it's become and now i'm
like overwhelmed by it all part of me
just wants to like burn my phone at this
point I don't know yeah well we do talk
about the technology addiction all the
time well i'll text you sometimes and
i'll be like i've checked my phone I got
that app and it's like I checked my
phone 147 times I just after noon I
won't get that app I don't want to know
yeah it's a scary doesn't like to work
just by picking it up literally like
every time you unlock it or something
yeah it's it's a lot I know if I'm up
for that yeah do you think it's changing
so basically I think you think it's
really good right that we've been able
to connect in this certain way yeah
we've seen a change I mean it's
literally changed governments in the
Middle yes and I think it's good because
I think people are getting sick of it on
a certain level or seeing its
intrusiveness yeah and so we're starting
to make natural boundaries around it
which I don't think for a few years we
were we were just like yeah facebook you
can have any data you want and now I
like I think about Facebook sometimes
and i think uh what have I done yeah
that's your imminent so how do you
balance it because I constantly am
dealing with trying to balance sharing
enough of my life and being a public
person and and trying to share something
for my audience and also maintaining
some level look you can accidentally put
in a geolocation where you know you to
me I was doing there for a while and
some lovely Twitter followers said to me
hey turn off your location services and
I'm like what's that and I go in and I'm
like holy [ __ ] people can find my house
probably literally
no you're tweeting on your toilet it's
too much that's location services
Kenny's bathroom yeah yeah but a net
good it's all in that good yes it is and
yet I find that I become very image
reputation oriented around this stuff
because we are people who are in the
entertainment industry and a lot of our
work now is completely filtered through
this stuff i mean we advertise
everything and we found my audience
through social media so it's like I have
an obligation to them but I've done
something interesting lately which is
this is just kind of part of my natural
progression as a human a human
progression thing um I love my dad
dearly mm-hmm but i'm no longer
discussing him on social media I done
love you dad we'll have to do another
topic on that just so i can get you to
fully yeah goodbye to that yes you say
goodbye to my dad on youtube that's a
whole it's prosser than that but yeah um
so yeah that's that's um yeah I'm done
yeah alright well I'm really curious
what do you guys think how much do you
share do you try to blend you know your
personal life and your professional life
are you anonymous right now we deal with
them that that's all are you even
watching you watching this really why
anybody watching anything which means
you're doing much better than we are
because we're here watching you watch us
comment right down below please